Today, I'm going to be
talking about some of the ways
that parsing out the functions
and packages in your files
can be helpful for organizing
and viewing projects.
And I'll also be
introducing a new package
I wrote called
funspotr that provides
some helpers for parsing,
analyzing and organizing
functions in different
project structures.
OK so I hope I'm not
the only one here
who maybe follow some of
their favorite R developers,
like a little too closely.
So, for example, like
before going to sleep
rather than scrolling
through Instagram,
I'll just scroll through
the recent GitHub activity
of my favorite R developers.
And then when a new
blog post or new book
comes out that I'm
super excited about,
it's like a major event for me.
And I just want to
jump straight in.
And I would love to say that I'm
just this sponge of information
and immediately
I'm just, you know,
know exactly what I'm doing.
But usually it ends up looking
a little bit more like this.
And, you know, there's all
these things coming at you
and you're trying to figure
out how these things relate
to each other.
And I've come up with
this kind of heuristic
where I'll just start
kind of writing down
the functions that I see as
I'm going through the new book
or blog or whatever it is.
And I'm happy that
I've seen other people
in the R community that kind of
share the same pattern as I do.
Here's a post or a tweet
from Alex Cookson where
he says any other
rstats people find
drob's Tidy Tuesday
screencast useful?
I made a spreadsheet
with timestamps
for hundreds of
specific tasks he does.
And then another example
from Jeff Rothschild,
who made something similar
for different developers
in the tidymodels space, particularly
Julia Silge and other authors
there.
And I think that creating
a reference table like this
for yourself can be
really helpful in terms
of building a mental model for
what's going on and printing
these different functions that
you can go back to and check on
and giving yourself a little
bit of context of the materials
that you're working through.
One downside with doing this
is it just takes a long time.
And you also may miss some
specific examples or packages
as you're going through
and creating these by hand.
And I think that this is where
something like funspotr
can be useful, either in
supplementing this material
or in creating an initial
reference table for yourself.
So I'm going to
start by just showing
what a typical funspotr
workflow looks like
and what the output looks like.
I'm going to give
you a few seconds
to kind of soak this in.
And this is also
another opportunity
if you find you can't read
the code to scoot closer up,
there's plenty of
seats in the front.
So I'll just give
you a few seconds
to see if you can soak this in.
So what I'm doing here is
I'm specifying the GitHub
repo where Julia
Silge's blog lives,
and then I'm just pulling out
all of the individual functions
and packages that
are used there.
And then we have links to the
relative paths within the repo,
as well as the URLs where
these files actually exist.
And then I think passing
something like this
into a nice little
HTML lookup table
can give you a nice
little reference
table for reviewing
whatever material
you're in the process
of going through.
So here I'm just
looking at where
are the cases where
she is used, written
about random forest
in the past and this
gives this nice little
way of looking this up.
Another place where this is
useful is just in those cases
where you kind of want
to sift through some set
of information.
You may not even remember
the function or package
that you saw her write about.
You just remember there was
something that was useful,
that I think she did.
And you just kind of want to
look through a reference sheet.
And I think that's also
where these types of tables
can be really helpful and
provide nice little supplements
to whatever other method
you use for searching
information or helping you kind
of in your learning process.
So next, I want to
talk a little bit
about each of the different
kind of groups of functions
that exist within funspotr.
So one set are these list files,
functions that essentially
take in some location and
return all the different files
in that location.
Then there's a set of
functions that spot things.
So in this case, we're talking
about spotting functions
and then have a variety of
helpers that either manipulate
the output of these objects
or are helpful for plotting.
And then there's also a bunch
of unexported functions
that I'm not really
going to get into today,
but can help with
certain situations
that you may run
into if you have
different dependency
structures than just
kind of the standard setup.
OK so now I'm going to
walk through this step
by step, just so you can see
the details of how this works.
So after running list files
GitHub repo, what we're
is returned are the file
paths for each of your R and R
Markdown files within that repo.
And then also the URLs to those.
Next, we pipe this into
spot funs files, which
is going to for each of
those individual file paths,
parse out the actual functions
and packages within them.
So if we just hone in
on an individual element
within that spotted
column, you'll
see this is where our actual
function packages that
are used within that file
exist, and then that next step,
the unnest result is just going to take
each of these individual data
frames containing
the function packages
and put them into a more
simple data frame structure
that you can use as a
reference table for yourself.
And where most of the
work that's going on here
is really in this spotting step.
And one thing about R that
adds a little bit of complexity
here is that when you
do a library call,
you're attaching all of the
functions within that package.
So what funspotr does is
essentially try and recreate
what it thinks that search
space is going to look like.
It takes a variety
of steps to do this.
So that when it identifies
a function, it can say,
I think this is the package
this function is
actually coming from.
I'll note, too, that
this takes a few seconds
to do for each file.
So while you can do it for
a few for hundreds of files,
if you try and do
it for millions,
this isn't going to work because
it's going to take too long.
If you have any like
ideas and suggestions
for how to do this
faster, definitely
feel free to open a GitHub
issue for me if you happen
to be an expert in this space.
And I'll also note
that if you don't
have the package
installed locally,
funspotr is not
going to know which
package that particular
function came from,
it's just going to say unknown.
So if you and if you don't
want to actually install
all of those packages that you
may have for some set of files
that you're running,
funspotr through.
If you don't want to install
those across all your projects,
you may want to start off
by using something like renv
so that you can keep the
packages you're installing
for this specific
to that project.
And again, this process of
recreating the search space
is currently set up to be
used on self-contained files.
And by that I just mean
picture like an R file
or an R Markdown file
that has a bunch of library
calls at the top.
So it's going to work on
things like repos for blogs
or books and things
more along those lines.
It's not going to work
so well on things like targets
workflows or Shiny apps
or other types of projects
that have more sophisticated
dependency structures,
potentially. That's just the
current set up more for these.
And again, the goal
here with this example
is to create some kind
of reference table
that you can use for yourself.
But outside of just
creating reference tables
for blogs or books
or screencasts,
I think another set of examples
are just your own code.
I know for me my own
code snippets can
get really disorganized
and tough to keep track of.
Here is a tweet
from Chelsea where
she says, I have so many
snippets of rstats code
and untitled files that
have useful bits of code
that I want to
catalog somewhere,
but I don't know where
would be best.
And I've definitely have this
experience, particularly
with my GitHub gists.
If you don't know
what GitHub gists are,
they're just like a
place online where you
can save little code snippets.
And for me, I'll make some
little example of something
and post it on GitHub gist and
then kind of forget about it.
And then sometime
down the road I'll
think, OK, I know I did
something along the space
and I can't quite
remember what that was.
And this is where I think
creating a little reference
table for yourself so that
you can go back through
and glance through
those or search
through what functions
and packages you
were using in your prior
examples can be really useful.
And this is I'm using this
example just for your own code,
but you could picture also
in an organizational context,
it may be useful to
get a sense do this
across a wide range of
different folder structures.
So you can see what
functions and packages
are different people using.
And just one little caveat
about these examples.
They're a little bit
manicured sometimes,
depending on what the
dependency structure looks like
or what the files that
you're actually saving look
like. There may be a
little bit of cleanup
that I'm kind of just
not exposing you to here
because I don't want to
scare you away too much.
So up to this point, I've gone
through a few examples where
we are just creating
reference tables for yourself,
but this can also be used for
actually directly organizing
your files.
And I'll walk through an
example using blogdown.
So I started blogging in
2020 after the RStudio conference
in San Francisco.
Rebecca Broder had
a really great talk
that inspired me to start
blogging more regularly,
and one issue I ran into
when creating my blogs
initially was my tags really
didn't-- weren't coherent at all.
I have ML, machine learning,
I have data science
spelled three different ways.
I have a bunch of synonyms
for each other for my tags.
So to the point that the tags
were really not any useful way
for actually
organizing my posts,
and I thought a better
way of organizing my post
would be to just directly see
which packages are being used
in each post and use those as
the way to actually organize
those tags.
So that's where
this function spot
tags can be really
helpful, where
what this does is when it
actually renders the file,
it first goes through checks,
checks which packages are
actually being used
and then puts those
into a format that it can
be used for the little tags
at the top of the
header for your post.
So now rather than
actually having
to put any thought into what
my tags should be for my blog,
I just have the spot tags.
It does all of that for me.
I don't need to
type anything out
and it can just kind
of like it's one less
thing to worry
about when blogging
can be a somewhat intimidating
thing to do in the first place.
And then if you
actually go and look
at what the tags section
of my website looks like,
all my posts are
organized based off
of whatever packages are
used within them, which
I think is this nice, clean,
coherent way of actually
setting things up.
So now I've talked
through some examples
of creating reference tables.
I just went through
an example of how
you can use this to organize
your files directly.
And the third area that I
just want to touch on really
briefly is I think it can also
be helpful to actually analyze
this information.
So there's a lot of
potential data here.
This is, again,
Julia Silge's blog.
Maybe we want to see how
do these different posts
and packages relate
to one another?
So here's another example
where I'm passing these
into this network plot.
In this case, I'm
actually just parsing out
the packages, not the functions.
So in the network plot we have,
each circle here represents
an individual
package, each square
represents an individual file.
The connections
represent those cases
where a package is loaded
within that particular script.
And you may notice that there's
some clustering of groups here.
And we see, OK, there's
these two big clusters.
One of these are packages
associated primarily
with the core
tidyverse, and then
another set of packages that
are associated primarily
with tidymodels.
So, you know, just
glancing this,
you get a sense
that Julia obviously
writes a lot about tidyverse
and about tidymodels,
and there's a lot of
tidyverse code in terms
of doing her cleanup.
You can imagine
another author who
writes more about
spatial analytics
may have some different set
of packages central to what
their posts are largely about.
And this is just
kind of one example,
but I think there's a
lot of different ways
you could take this.
You can imagine trying to
explore the relatedness
between different projects or
between what different authors
are writing about.
Or you could also use
this to help organize
those files directly based off
of like what types of things
actually exist within them.
So this is just kind of like
a little taster example,
but I think there's a
lot of interesting things
you could do here.
And I just want to reference a
few other interesting projects.
This is not within the
R community directly,
but if you're just interested
in visualizing code space
or using visualizing code repos
or using the information that's
within the files to help
organize those files.
These are just a couple
of other projects
I think are worth looking
into if you're interested.
So I hope that you will
take the jump in and try out
the package.
I'm planning on submitting it
to CRAN in the next few weeks,
so if you try it, I'd love
to get feedback from you.
And I also have
on my README just
like a few examples
of reference tables
created using funspotr.
If you use this and create
some reference table,
definitely open up an
issue or a pull request
and I'd be happy to
add that there just
to get some other examples.
So, thank you.